hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the 2019 you brought our
chess masters it's a game between
Chinese Grand Master Yu yang Yi and
Russian Grand Master of Ladislav
Artemyev and now we've already shown one
game by vladislav our team it was also
from the 2019 Gibraltar chess masters
where he defeated the Grandmaster Hikaru
Nakamura and both of them are having an
excellent tournament so far both of them
without a loss in the previous round you
young defeated Vietnamese grand master
lock want Liam and the Vladislav
artemiev defeated David navara so both
of them are ready to win this tournament
artemiy was going into this last round
with seven and a half points whereas the
you young G is going with seven points
so there is a bit of a difference but
both of them are still we're hoping to
win the tournament now it's an excellent
game so without further ado let's check
it out then sorry that we haven't shown
more games from this very nice
tournament but it's a shame it's you
know it's just collides with the tata
steel so more than half the tournament
is already over before tata steel ends
and you know it's it would be too much
time to show games from both tournaments
the tournament so I don't know it's
either a good thing or a bad thing you
know it's either a good thing that there
are so many chess tournaments in the
world that you know there's just not
enough time separately for each but then
again you can't show all of them I mean
I can show them you can watch them
somewhere else but still even if you
watch the live coverage you can't watch
to live coverages at a time I mean you
could but I sometimes do that but you
know it's it's it's a tough work but
okay now getting back to this game you
young giver slot Aslam Artemyev in the
last round both of them hoping to win it
and we have efore by you young ec6 the
caro-kann defense d4 d5 and now II five
and artemyev doesn't go for the sneaky
c5 you know the whole transposing into
the French with the tempo down but
rather goes to Bishop to f5 he offers a
young e to go for the bayonet bayonet
attack but he goes Knight to f3 the
short variation we have E six Bishop to
e2 night
d7 this is all standard theory there are
so many games played with this exact
same variation in the database we have
castles and Bishop to g6 and here our
team we have already played this
position with the black pieces in 2018
in Skopje he defeated David Navarro
Navarre I had the white pieces here
Navarre played Knight bTW too but here
young he comes prepared
and he goes c3 a different line but also
nothing new you know theory wise and
here we have a knight to h6 you have to
develop this night somehow and here
black just offers if white would like to
give up the bishop air for some messing
up of the pawn structure on the Kings
side and it's not it's not a new move or
anything there are I found 38 games in
the database with this exact same move
and black didn't really have any good
results in in most of them but ok we
have a four also a non move and here in
every game available Knight to f5 was
played so black did not allow white to
spoil his pawn structure with dis
captures and f5 is a nice square for the
knight if white wants to kick it away he
will have to push g4 at some point but
here we have a 5 by Artemyev and this is
now a new move now we are unmoved 8 and
we have a completely new game so let's
see we have Knight to h3 young he
developed the night this way he wants to
go a night c2 night II 1 and then to d3
or f3 depending on how the game goes
Bishop to e7 artemyev is ready to castle
and now Knight c2 are-- maneuvering we
have castles knights e2 e1 and now comes
c5 here our teammate is just pretending
like he doesn't have a funny night on h6
but he does so we have Bishop captures
on h6 giving up the bishop pair but also
ruining black's pawn structure on the
Kings side and Bishop to b5 ok we have C
capture somebody for C character Sunday
for and not Knights to b8 now our
teammate wants to remain over his knight
he wants to go to a6 or c6 and then as
he does have a very nice outpost for his
knight on before white will either have
to give up even the lights were Bishop
to prevent this or simply allowed this
knight to come to b4 and
the White has no a pond or C pond to
kick the night away from before it will
be like we said an excellent outpost
Queen to d2 now young he wants to grab
that h6 pawn Artemia defense it came to
g7 and not Knights to d3 we have nice -
Asics going for that before outpost and
now nice the F for pressuring the bishop
here but also in some lines also
preparing Knight to h5 check as we'll
see very soon we have Queen to b6
putting pressure on the d4 pawn but also
if the bishop moves the b2 pawn will be
somewhat threatened but but okay the
queen is now developed the rooks are
connected and here if you capture you
don't really gain anything you will just
fix black's pawn structure on the King
side so here we have H for leaving the
option of playing h5 in the future if
needed and black just goes rook F the c8
here Artemia if h5 it doesn't really do
anything the bishop can always go to e4
you will not be able to kick it away
from there but here the bishop and the
rook are really controlling the entire
board nicely rook the c2 would be an
excellent move for black if black would
be able to do this then the other Brooke
is coming to c8 and already black will
be so much better so of course white has
to prevent this we have rook FC 1 and
now rook captures rook captures and now
Knight to be 4 finally the night finds
itself on this very nice before we have
g3 strengthening the h4 pawn also
another night from f3 can move and now
we have Knight 2 a 2 and here black
sneakily winds the winds over the C file
white could try something like rook to a
1 here it would be interesting but what
immediately went rook to d1 I thought
looked to a-1 would be interesting
because now you have to go back with the
knife for example night before and then
rook the c1 nah not the repeat moves as
to achieve a draw by threefold
repetition but maybe just to see if
black was interested in a draw by
threefold repetition and also to maybe
see if black would repeat because our
teammate is in the lead in a tournament
he also wants to win this game so maybe
he would try to you know go for a
different plan like knight c6
something but at least you would see
where you stand and it doesn't cost you
anything if anything you are you know
moving closer to move 40 to reach time
control so you will get more time but
okay after night they to look to be one
immediately not checking you for team
you would perhaps be interested in a row
and now look to see it artemyev wins the
C file and here again rook to e1 now
would be too slow you don't have the
option of trying this now because now
rook the c2 is coming and now well it
would be an interesting variation now
Knight to h5 is actually a very nice
move you can't move the King because of
Queen captures on h6 then white would be
winning now you have to capture here and
then after Queen captures rook Bishop
captures on f3 and after rook captures
only two Queen captures on d4 is coming
and here white would be up the exchange
but black would have the bishop pair
still and would be up upon so definitely
excellent compensation for being down
the exchange but are instead of this
idea rope to a one yongi tries a
different approach it plays Knight to h2
now if this same idea happens again at
least there will not be a knight on f3
to capture after the night on h5 is
captured so now if rook to c2 is played
in now you have night h5 check Bishop
captures and now Queen captures in c2
night before attacks the Queen Bishop
care or the Queen can move Bishop
captures on d1 now Queen captures on d1
and we would have this endgame not an
endgame but almost an endgame the
Queen's are still on the board but why
it would be somewhat better do to blacks
you know corrupted pawn structure on the
King said you could go Queen g4 check
queen h5 will go Knight g4 attack the h6
pawn what would be better here so after
Knight - H - of course Artemia does not
go for rook to c2 you don't want to make
hasty moves in the final round as you've
had an excellent tournament so far Queen
to c7 now making this rook Queen battery
on the C file preparing Queen to c2 now
and ok Bishop to d3 preventing Queen to
c2 but also offering a trade of bishops
we have h5 black now finally plays its
it doesn't allow white to push h5 and
now we have G
now young he is going all out he he
wants he wants to win this game
we have Knights the before now attacking
the bishop here but also forcing the
exchange the ship characters we have H
captures and now comes G captors on H 5
and here quit not recapturing and
allowing this to capture with check but
Queen to c2 now we have h captures on g6
Artemyev here sacrifices upon but for
very good reason now he goes Queen to f5
and he threatens Quintus rook to c2 now
this possibility of leukemic the c2 is
once again introduced and here you could
go for another pawn grab for example if
you capture on f7 it's still possible
but after rook c2 you have to go Queen
e3 and then after Bishop captures on h4
threatening to capture on f2 you have to
go Knight to h3 and here after King
characters it seems that white holds
this and that it is possible to play
this for white but you young he tries a
different approach he it's you know the
last round most likely her time is
running so he didn't go for this yet
another pawn grab rather he goes Queen
to e3 moves the Queen before rook lands
and c2 and only now will he recapture if
black doesn't do anything hasty but we
have F captors and g6 Artyom now grabs
the pawn and now comes Queen g3 so
pressuring that pawn here but also if
the Queen ever moves then ideas like
Knight h5 or Knight captures on e6 will
become a possibility we have looked to a
fate here now threatening to capture the
knight on f4 we're Knight the g2 get it
guarded way and also the knight now
keeps keeps an eye on this h4 pawn as
well but here Queen back to c2 attacking
the rook on d1 the pawn on b2 and also
the pawn on e4 and here young he just
goes Knight back to e3 defends the rook
and says okay you can capture either of
the pawns but if you captured upon than
h5 white start the attack and you don't
want your Queen to be out of the game
it's it's a very important game so after
93 we have Queen back to e4 leaving
white with the option of deciding how to
this game so here the d4 pawn is very
weak the queen is attacking it so night
is coming to c6 and then it will be very
hard to defend this pawn so here young
he tries this next idea he goes the
knight eat the g4 makes room for the
Queen to come to e3 for when the pawn is
under attack
we have knight c6 Artemia finds a way to
make it work we have Queen to e3 and now
rook to f4 now pressuring three times
the d4 pawn but also the Queen and rook
are attacking the knight here and here
young he finds the correct reply Knight
to f6 he attacks the Queen and forces a
trade on f6 we have Bishop captures pawn
captures with check King captures and
now Queen captures on e4 rook captures
on e4 and now Knight to f3 defends the
d4 pawn as its attacked twice but okay
now the rook and Knight are defending it
and also the knight from F three guards
the h4 pawn but here are Tamia finds a
very nice plan he goes night here
once the remain over the Knight to a5
from where it will attack both the d4
pawn and the h4 pawn we have King to g2
and now comes Knight to f5 and now you
can see that this pawn is attacked twice
by the rook and by the knight but also
this pawn is now attacked why so it's
very hard to defend both if you look
into h3
then you can see that both the knight
the rook and the King are stuck guarding
the d4 pawn and d h4 point as well again
using the green color as you enjoyed it
so much but yeah it would be just a too
passive position for whites to hold you
can just go rookie too and you know have
a have a feast
you know just gobble everything up so
after Knight to f5 with rook the d3 are
young he tries an active plan but you
know you have to give up at least a pawn
Knight captures with check we have
Knight captures rook captures on h4 and
now King to g3
we have g5 it defends the rook and now
again it's not not all that clear what
to do here you might want to bring your
King over to the center of the board you
can go something like in the three
rookie three
check trades rooks and it wins for black
on the other hand you can't your look is
stuck guarding the d4 point if you try
something like this to grab the b7 pawn
black grabs two points for your one
point so it's again not possible your
black would be up too much material so
here after g5 we have King to g2 white
just Waits now to see what our Timmy
will do and we have rook to e4 King back
to g3 and now came to f5 we have King
back to g2 and now G for just grabbing
more space in front of the White King
King to f1 and now comes b6 white goes
King to g2 just waiting to see what
black will do and now comes a rook to e1
making room for the King on e4 now we
have b3 and now it's a white seems to be
holding everything but there is a very
nice way for for black to win this
position you know if you want feel free
to pause the video here and just try to
you know muster up a plan how to go
about this position artemius
plan was really really awesome so I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who did pause the video and try
to find the correct idea here
congratulations it's it's a really nice
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
King to e4 the rook is now overloaded
the rope has to protect the d4 pawn but
also the b3 pawn because the black rook
will attack it via Luke 2 b1
so we have worked the d2 and now rook
the b1 attacking the b3 pawn now comes
King to g3 now white forces black King
to move back because you don't want to
lose the g4 point we have King back to
f5 and now the rook returns to d3 and
again the white rook is able to guard
both of the points but now here's the
problem here black plays rook to h1 and
now it all becomes clear now the king
was forced to come to g3 the rook is not
allowed to h1 and now rook to h3 there
is no way to prevent this now here
White's ride King to g2 but Artemia
nevertheless played rook to h3 and it
was in this position that young e
resigned
the game why did you resign because even
if he wins the pawn it's not enough root
character spawn captors and hidden
captors once the King comes to e4 it's
all over now you can just go let say
King g3 King chapters on d4 you are
already down too much material King
before you can go King c3 King e5 and
now you can just push this one to
victory you Queen so much faster and you
can just gobble up all the other points
as well Queen three check it doesn't
really matter you can do whatever you
want a completely winning position and
on the other hand after rook to h3 even
if you don't capture it there's not all
that much you can do you can move the
rook you're gonna lose the b3 pawn and
if you try something like rook III
doesn't really matter black will still
capture and every bond captures King
still comes to e4 and now it's even
better for black King f2 let's say try
this g3 check you force the King back
either the King will go here and then
you'll for you know force him to go back
by threatening to promote the Jeep on or
you will capture then King captures and
I will capture here and then you just
move the King you know just go here push
all the points and win the game oh but
yeah after rook to h3 you yongi resigned
and Vladislav Artemia went from seven
and a half to eight and a half points as
you can see here but before I show you
the standings after round 10 of the 2019
Gibraltar chess masters let's just check
up on all of Artemis opponents from this
tournament this is a the graphics it is
from a chess 24 website there you can
always check who played who you can
check on all of the games it's all free
so very very very nifty but yeah there
you can see eight and a half out of ten
points he won 27 rating points this
tournament which is insane if you're
rated 27 10 27 9 in this case as you can
see seven wins and three draws and the
three draws being only he drew against
Fernando Peralta of Argentina he draw
against maxime beaugeois graviton still
Evan Aragon and all the other games he
won greatest ones being David Navarro
and Hikaru Nakamura it would seem but
yeah an outstanding tournament and yeah
we already met
he finished sixth in the world bliss
championship he finished third in the
world wrapper championship now he wins
the Gibraltar chess festival
I think you know Vladislav artemiev is
the demand watch out for in this year
and the years to come
but you know we'll see we'll see what
happens because when I was a covering
the 2018 blitz and rapid world
championship I said okay now Artemyev is
now awesome in blitz and rapid but he he
still has to prove himself in the
classical and now he definitely does so
so yeah and also we said we would show
the standings there you have it what is
love our team have a time eight and a
half out of ten after 10 rounds some of
the games were still being played while
I was recording this but I don't think
those games would affect the standings
in the first 25 so there we have it also
an outstanding performance by Indian
Grandmaster Morley karttikeya who also
have has eight out of ten points but
kind of kind of unfortunately for him
overshadowed by voiceover Timmy with
eight and a half out of ten but still
you can see even Murali
we take eight out of ten you know ahead
of Nikita we do gov David Howell
David Anton Guajardo David Navarre and
Neil's grand alias 12 bubble laQuan Liam
even charge my countrymen also in
excellent tenth place with seven out of
ten Wesley so then you young ye maxima
Sheila Grove Michael Aaron skittle Alec
Cinco
Hikaru Nakamura in 16th place aroma
edward rough Mahmoud of pavulon of grant
cumin Maxie Matlock of Gyeonggi tan
Mario music also in excellent 23rd place
11 Aragon in 24th and Surrey vibe of in
25th place so you know we already
mentioned in that game between our team
is the Nakamura
it's a tournament you know it's a
monstrosity of a tournament over 100
grandmasters participating so any any
place you get in the let's like we shown
here in the top 25 is beyond excellent
so winning a tournament like this for
whatever team you have completely insane
congratulations
to him and you know definitely interest
I believe he's now even rating wise he's
almost twenty seven fifty so he will be
invited to I believe all the tournaments
it's gonna be really cool to watch him
play yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you've enjoyed this
very short coverage of the 2019
Gibraltar chess masters I would like to
thank Gregory wired Mike van der drift
buoyancy which which Fernando esta vez
de Oliviera and Paul Hirst for a
contribution to my channel thinking a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
one of them the top left one will be a
cos pervs game against Vladimir Kramnik
1990 season two check it out if you
haven't it's really insane it's like a
tribute to kramnik for his early
retirement but yeah like I said I'm sure
we'll be seeing much more of him and
yeah thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon